le rire et le langage universel de la
joie qui transcende les frontières
les bébés ça même rire avant de parler
mais si tu croyais que rigoler était un
acte innocent tu vas voir que les
scientifiques ont découvert que nous
excès d'hilarité pourrait tempête caché
de secret peu à boire soit prévenu après
cette vidéo avec l'ami goa tu ne rira
plus jamais de la même façon peut-on
vraiment mourir de rire mdr mort de rire
mais est ce vraiment possible parce
qu'en soit mourir de rire ce serait pas
complètement improbable quand tu es prix
d'un bon gros rires tu peux finir au sol
avec des difficultés à respirer et même
des douleurs aux côtes tout ton corps
est secoué de spasmes et on se dit que
ça peut partir en cacahuète et maui
depuis l'antiquité le rire est coupable
d'une longue liste de meurtres asphyxie
syncope épilepsie étouffement
dislocation de la mâchoire dekker qui
monte jusqu'à 500 battements par minute
les détails font froid dans le dos par
exemple chrissyb de soles philosophes de
l'antiquité est retrouvé mort d'un fou
rire au cours d'un banquet en regardant
un âne manger des figues il dit à sa
propriétaire donne maintenant à cette
halle un peu de vin pur pour faire
également passé les figues
alors oui rien de droit la première vue
mais en grec antique années 20
s'écrivent ainsi un jeu de mots qui aura
eu raison de ce grand philosophe grec
mort de sa propre blague mais pas besoin
de remonter à l'antiquité pour retrouver
des cas de mort de rire en 1975 un
anglais alex mitchell est décédé en
riant à l'une des six émissions
télévisées préférées
c'est à cause d'un sketch comique
télévisé à base de ni john tilt qu'il
aurait rigolé sans s'arrêter pendant 25
minutes avant de succomber à un arrêt
cardiaque
pas rancunière sa femme a envoyé une
lettre au studio télé pour les remercier
d'avoir rendu les derniers instants de
son mari si plaisant mais qu'est ce qui
rend le rire si mortel
le problème c'est que le rire est un
réflexe est actionné par notre système
limbique cette partie du cerveau où
naissent nos émotions et qui nous
servent aussi de pilote automatique
s'ils venaient à se désactiver
tu serais par exemple obligé de penser à
actionner des poumons pour respirer
imagine l'angoissé
le truc c'est que tu n'as aucun contrôle
sur lui genre là maintenant et c'est un
peu d'arrêter ton coeur vas-y pensé très
fort quoi moi si tu y arrives les
chercheurs du monde entier vont vouloir
étudier bon le seul problème c'est que
tu le sera probablement morts bref tout
comme tout coeur et des poumons le rire
est très difficile à contrôler une fois
lancée difficile de le stopper et cité
asthmatiques ou que tu as des problèmes
cardiaques
bah ça peut tourner au cauchemar
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu savais qu'on
pouvait aussi rire pendant notre sommeil
c'est même assez commun puisque trois
personnes sur quatre aurait déjà riz au
moins une fois lors d'un rêve
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui arrive est un
thaïlandais au bout de cinq minutes à se
taper une barre non-stop sa femme s'est
quand même dit que bon ça commence à
faire long quand même il ne s'est jamais
arrêté de rire
jusqu'à ce qu'il meure d'une a6 je sais
pas vous mais moi j'aurai vraiment bien
voulu savoir de quoi il rêvait mais
récemment une nouvelle façon de mourir a
fait son apparition le protoxyde d'azoté
ces petites cartouches de gaz hilarant
tu sembles être un mode de défense de
plus en plus prisée chez les ados à tel
point que c'est maintenant la seconde
substances psychoactives consommer chez
les jeunes après le cannabis mais cette
pratique peut entraîner de graves
séquelles cérébrales voire la mort
imagine en plein fou rire chimique avec
tes potes tu est soudain pris d'une
crampe aux abdos tu ne peux plus
respirer mais la substance t'empêche de
reprendre le contrôle sur ton corps et
tu asphyxie lentement sous les yeux de
tes amis éclaté de rire malgré eux n'est
pas assez tragique pour toi ça tombe
bien il existe une façon encore plus
sombre de mourir de rire
c'est une maladie observé en papouasie
le courroux surnommée la maladie du rire
qu'il faut des dizaines d'années avant
que les symptômes apparaissent chez les
contaminer il commence à avoir des fous
rires nerveux sans aucune raison puis au
bout d'un an le malade commence à perdre
le contrôle de son corps et enfin
la cause un jour un papou à développer
spontanément un prion une protéine
anormalement replié dans son corps une
fois dans le corps ça provoque une
réaction en chaîne dans le système
nerveux jusqu'au rire incontrôlable puis
à terme la mort mais puisque le prion
n'est pas un virus ou une bactérie et
qu'il n'est pas non plus héréditaires
les médecins se sont demandés comment
s'est-il transmis à autant de gens la
réponse me glacer le sang les papous ont
directement à gérer le prion lors d'un
rite funéraire très glauque
ils ont bouffé la cervelle de leurs
ancêtres morts du courroux c'est censé
leur permettre d'acquérir la sagesse des
anciens n'ont pas ici ça aurait été sa
folie
le rire est le propre de l'homme on le
voit bien les animaux sont aussi
capables de se taper de bonnes barres le
premier observé ça c'est ni plus ni
moins que charles darwin
il s'est amusé à chatouiller des singes
pour observer leurs réactions ils ont
confié les bougres paradoxalement le
rire peut exprimer chez les primates
d'autres sentiments comme la tristesse
la colère même la peur mais ils ne sont
pas les seuls
chez les rats par exemple vous n'avez
jamais entendu rire et pourtant
l'institut oui mais ce petit sont
proches des ultra sons on dirait un rire
et il semble activé chez le rat les
mêmes zones cérébrales que celle d'un
enfant qui rit on remarque aussi que
quand le chien respire en ouvrant la
bouche pour faire baisser sa température
ce qu'on appelle le halètement ça peut
parfois ressembler un rire humain au
début des années 2000 la psychologue et
comportementaliste animal patricia
simonet a mené des recherches
révolutionnaires sur les vocalisations
faites par les chiens elle a découvert
que quand deux chiens se rencontrer
jouent tous les deux utilisent quatre
façons de communiquer différentes
aboiements grognements gémissements et
une expiration forcé qui ressemble un
peu à un reer par contre c'est pas
vraiment à rire comme celui des humains
bah ouais les animaux ne pensent pas
comme nous ils n'ont pas du tout la même
perception de ce qui est marrant ou pas
femme qui rit à moitié dans ton lit
psychologues sociologues anthropologues
et d'autres gens avec des métiers en
hawks se sont penchés sur le sujet et
ils semblent d'accord pour dire que pour
la séduction le rire a deux fonctions
la première est plutôt évidente ça fait
partie de la parade nuptiale chez la
femme c'est une façon indirecte de dire
à l'homme
dis donc tu me plais bien toi et ça
permettrait en plus de relâcher sa
tension sexuelle mais la deuxième raison
est un peu moins flatteuse le rire
serait un mode d'autodéfense une façon
d'adoucir l'homme en face qui peut
représenter une menace physique la
séduction peut aussi représenter un
moment stressant limite traumatique chez
certaines femmes le corps temps à
l'ordre d'évacuer ce stress par le rire
quand ils rigolent la table hague
qu'est-ce qui saigne qui à deux pattes
tu ne peux pas savoir si c'est parce
qu'elle est sous le charme ou si c'est
parce qu'elle a peur il n'y a pas de
science exacte sur ce point par exemple
il est possible de rire pendant ou après
l'amour est ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est stressé qu'elle te trouve ridicule
ou juste que l'avalanche d'endorphines
dans son cerveau lui fait perdre la tête
les trois solutions sont valides mais
bon après si tu as sorti ton déguisement
de petit cochon je crois de connaître la
réponse le rire est une drogue on a vu
que le rire permettait à notre corps de
s'apaiser
le rire déclenché dans notre sens un
shot d'hormones qui va perturber notre
état mental et on ne parle pas d'un bac
sentiment de contentement
en effet les chercheurs de stanford ont
découvert grâce à plusieurs irm qu'un
gros fous rires active les mêmes zones
du cerveau qu'une injection de cocaïne
l'histoire d'un homme va montrer à tous
à quel point il ne faut pas sous-estimer
les effets chimiques du rire ce monsieur
c'est norman cousin et les médecins vont
lui apprendre qu'il est atteint d'une
maladie incurable de la colonne
vertébrale
il ne lui donne même pas une chance sur
500 et survit pire ces derniers mois
risquent d'être extrêmement douloureux
mais norman décide de se battre pour sa
vie ayant une formation médicale
il prend son propre traitement en main
et c'est pour ça qu'il va quitter
l'hôpital pour fuir son atmosphère
lugubre
il diminue les antidouleurs qu on lui
prescrit car il veut éviter leurs effets
secondaires sont anti douleur à lui ça
sera le rire c'est pourquoi il s'achète
tout un stock de films comiques et de
caméras cachées chaque jour il se
regarde quelques épisodes et rigole
beaucoup
ses souffrances ses faces lui permettant
ainsi de dormir mais quand la douleur se
réveille il recommence à zéro
et petit à petit cette cure de rire lui
permet d'arrêter complètement les
médicaments tous les médecins le savent
le moral d'un patient a une grande
influence sur sa santé mais norman
cousin va faire ce que tous croyaient
impossible
il va survivre guérir et reprendre sa
vie normale font comprendre cet exploit
les médecins ont analysé les substances
chimiques sécréter lors du rire ils ont
découvert qu'on retrouve principalement
de l'endorphine qu'on appelle aussi
l'hormone du bonheur et c'est pas pour
rien puisque son action est similaire à
celle de l'opium le liquide dont on
extrait la morphine un puissant anti
douleur quand les médecins ont compris
ce superbe
du rire ils ont commencé à faire venir
des clowns dans les hôpitaux et les
résultats furent sans appel ils ont
constaté que ça leur permettait de
réduire la dose d'anesthésiant des
patients de 30% et ainsi accélérer leur
convalescence
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle déjà des
tribus indiennes avaient des clowns
guérisseur qui se servait du haschich
pour déclencher le rire et et soigner
les douleurs et même en grèce antique
ont installé les hôpitaux à côté du
théâtre afin que les malades puissent
entendre les rires du public comme ici à
epidaure un haut lieu de la médecine
antique centré autour de son prestigieux
théâtre à epidaure voir des spectacles
faisait partie des soins depuis l'année
2000 des gens ont même commencé à former
des groupes pour ce shooter au reer ci
s'appelle la rigologie ou le yoga du
rire
la magie c'est que notre corps ne fait
pas la différence entre un vrai fort c
est un rire spontané
donc la prochaine fois que tu te sens
angoissé ou de mauvaise humeur et c'est
fort ce taux à rire comme un demeuré
pendant 20 secondes
d'ailleurs cet homme au nom
imprononçable qui détient le record
mondial du rire le plus long en ayant
pris plus de trois heures prend ça très
au sérieux il a carrément l'ambition de
construire des villages du rire ou ceux
qui ne sourit pas aurait des amendements
bon maintenant est ce que c'est un monde
de bisounours ou une angoisse totale
l'avenir nous le dira pourquoi le rire
des fous nous glacent le sang
pourquoi les méchants toujours ce rire
diabolique qui font froid dans le dos
pour le comprendre imagine toi dans une
jungle préhistorique avec toute la tribu
d'un tu entend du bruit dans les
buissons tout ton corps se fige prêt à
prendre la fuite l'adrénaline se déverse
dans ton sens mais une seconde plus tard
c'est une ridicule lièvre qui sort de sa
cachette un réel libérateur jaillit de
tagore tous ces hormones de stress
activé pour rien ton corps va les
évacuer par le rire en même temps il va
avoir une fonction sociale
il va signifier à toute ta tribu que le
danger est passé et que tout le monde
peut se détendre et que se passe-t-il
quand quelqu'un rigole alors qu'il n'y a
aucune raison ou même à contre sens
c'est-à-dire pendant le danger notre
cerveau devient confus et se demande
s'il peut se détendre ou pas les signaux
sont contradictoires ce qui provoque une
sensation de malaise
instinctivement nous allons donc nous
méfier voir rejeter les rieurs qui
envoient des faux signaux c'est pourquoi
les rire machiavélique des méchants face
alors clim nous glacent le sang ça peut
également expliquer la peur des clowns
qu'ont certaines personnes encore mieux
le rire pourrait être un indice pour
détecter les psychopathes
tu te rappelles le rôle social du rire
qui permet d'envoyer un signal à toute
la tribu chaque individu va à son tour
relayé ce message c'est pourquoi le rire
est contagieux
en fait ton cerveau est branché pour
rire dès que tu vois tes amis rire un
peu comme quand tu vois quelqu'un va y
est
ce mécanisme est déclenché par ce qu'on
appelle les neurones miroirs quand on
observe quelques uns sont en prise d'une
émotion il est actif chez nous cette
même émotion c'est tellement efficace
que les scientifiques ont observé qu on
a trente fois plus de chances de rire
quand on est avec d'autres personnes
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que certaines
séries comiques met des rires
préenregistrés qu'on appelle aussi les
rires en conserve
ça permet de toujours faire mieux passer
les blagues même si elles sont pas très
drôle
toutefois cette tendance à partager les
émotions de nos semblables qu'on appelle
l'empathie est absente scheer environ 1%
de la population ces personnes se
soucient peu de ce que ressentent les
autres voir une personne souffrir les
laisse indifférente leurs neurones
miroirs fonctionne normalement ils sont
atteints de troubles psychopathe
donc voilà si dans un groupe tu fais une
blague et qu'une personne ne rigole pas
c'est peut-être un psychopathe ou alors
t'es pas drôle j'espère que vous avez
appris plein de choses sur le rire et
que vous allez continuer à nous suivre
dans cette aventure
donc pensez bien vous abonner et activer
la cloche merci à antoine pour cette
vidéo les monteurs doit fise hegoa sans
qui rien ne serait possible
on se dit à bientôt et de votre côté
continué de rire mais avec modération
ciao
[Musique]